said the government had to be careful
not to declare victory too soon in the
financial crisis
he testified before a panel overseeing
the troubled asset relief program
this is two hours the hearing of the
congressional oversight panel over tarp
with secretary of the treasury geithner
is now called to order
welcome mr secretary uh to your third
appearance before the congressional
oversight panel
we appreciate your being here and
appreciate your commitment to coming
every quarter um yesterday this panel
released its monthly oversight report
for december
it was a comprehensive assessment of
tarps
uh accomplishments and an exploration of
the places where tarp has fallen
short uh you made it a busy news day
by announcing at the same time uh
that treasury will extend tarp until
october of next year
thus it seems that between the two of us
we have intensified a vigorous debate
here in congress
about what direction the program should
take going forward
as the starting place for our
conversation i want to note the
conclusion of
our report tarp was an important part of
the government's rescue
strategy and it helped rescue the
financial system from
imminent collapse the apocalyptic fears
that we were all suffering 14 months ago
have not come to pass
and for that we owe a great debt of
gratitude to the public servants who
toiled through the darkest days
of this crisis but as the report
also highlights tarp has been far
from an unmitigated success credit for
consumers in small businesses
remains scarce the foreclosure crisis
continues unabated
and treasuries mitigation programs have
not achieved the scope
the scale or the permanence necessary to
stabilize the housing market
large banks survive the crisis with the
help of government support
but smaller banks continue to fail at
nearly unprecedented rates
and the fdic is in the red for the first
time in 17 years
perhaps most disturbing of all tarp
created an implicit
government guarantee for major financial
institutions
a guarantee that is not shared by their
smaller counterparts
the unprecedented government actions
taken to stabilize the system
have created a huge moral hazard that
makes our system
riskier and that infects the pricing of
assets
we welcome you here today mr secretary
to engage in the constructive process of
evaluating the tarp
and assessing whether it is serving
taxpayers in the manner that was
intended
i look forward to your testimony and a
productive discussion
and with that i call on mr atkins
for two minutes of remarks
all right okay thanks thank you madam
chairman
and welcome secretary geithner milton
friedman once said that
nothing is so permanent as a temporary
government program
yesterday we learned that what most of
us had already suspected
that tarp will not die at the end of
this year
the program is no longer i think no
longer can be considered
a hastily arranged effort to arrest the
financial free fall
i can understand why a treasury
secretary any treasury secretary really
would want to extend tarp
why not it's a free option at taxpayer
expense
and essentially a blank check to finance
any macroeconomic stimulus initiative
that the executive branch
can imagine to the tune of hundreds of
billions of dollars
but now that last year's emergency has
abated the rationale behind tarp
as a salve for financial markets in
distress
no longer supports treasury's choice i
believe to extend it
the previous congress reluctantly
authorized tarp in response to an
extraordinary financial panic
would congress today approve tarp i
cannot imagine it
that essentially is why it was extended
i believe
but to extend tarp borders i think on
recklessness and irresponsibility in
treasury's role as a steward of the
nation's financial system
tarp continues to inflict great economic
costs both directly
directly to the taxpayer in form of
actual and potential tens of billions of
dollars of losses
and indirectly as chair a woman said of
moral hazard distorted incentives
created by
implicit government guarantees and
inefficient government interference in
the operation of private firms
moreover the administration's
legislative proposals will not solve
these problems i believe but only
institutionalize them
now that unbridled financial panic that
was cited as the original justification
for tarp has disappeared
why deepen and prolong these costs i
think we're still too close to the
events of last year to determine whether
tarp was a success
i'm not convinced that we can even yet
credit the program itself for stopping a
panic in the markets
the united states government basically
threw eight trillion dollars
in the form of guarantees loans and
direct outlays at the financial markets
something had to happen out of all that
liquidity
and in fact i think this chart here
shows
how tarp rates as but a small portion
of the total government outlays this
little
red triangle here compared to everything
else guarantees outlays and loans
that the federal government did last
year
so the lack of political accountability
i believe may be tarp's
greatest liability of all and i think
the treasury department has done
very little to assuage many obvious
oversight concerns
that this panel has expressed first
treasury takes the position that tarp
essentially is a revolving line of
credit
with a 700 billion dollar limit on
outstanding balances in any time
at your previous appearance before the
panel i asked for a legal opinion
justifying the view that tarp is a
revolving fund
but we have yet to receive such an
opinion from treasury
i believe that this mission needs to be
addressed as soon as possible
so i thank you
uh mr silvers uh good morning and thank
you chairman warren
um i wish to begin by saying mr
secretary that
i believe the administration's decision
to extend tarp was the only responsible
course of action
the financial system today is not
fundamentally stable in my opinion
the mortgage foreclosure crisis is
accelerating and the overall economic
situation particularly when looked at
globally
is not good the risk of a systemic
problem in the coming months is
significant
while i believe a tough resolution
authority such as
proposed by the obama administration and
being acted on hopefully by the uh in
the house uh in the coming hours
would be far superior to tarp as a means
of dealing with a possible future
financial crisis
at the moment congress has not passed
any such authority
in this context the administration's
decision was the only responsible one
and as i think you could you just got a
little taste of it was an act of
political courage
which i think you deserve a substantial
amount of credit
now we found in our december report uh
released earlier this week
that tarp played a positive role in
halting a runaway financial crisis in
the fall of last year
i recognize this is hard to prove in the
way that a mathematician would prove
something but i'm
completely convinced this is true and
the reason i think this is true
and the reason why my colleague mr
atkins has it wrong
is because there's a difference between
liquidity and equity
now nonetheless tarp is wildly unpopular
among the american public
and this is not because the public does
not understand what happened
it's because the public understands all
too well what happened
this panel is found in report after
report that tarp transactions have been
undertaken on less than fair terms to
the public
that there have been issues of
transparency in key tarp actions
including the stress tests
that the underlying weaknesses in the
financial system have been inadequately
addressed
and finally and perhaps most importantly
the key credit markets that matter to
the american public remain weak
with real consequences for jobs it did
not have to be this way
and it does not have to be this way in
the future
this administration has taken
significant steps to make tarp a program
that works in the interests of the
american people
and not simply in the interests of the
financial firms we bailed out
including allocating significant monies
to foreclosure relief
and managing to avoid putting more money
into the large banks
but more must be done tarpon in second
year must one
work for main street not just wall
street two
always transact with private parties on
terms that are fair to the american
public
and three address the underlying
weaknesses in our large financial
institutions by cleaning up firms that
are broken
rather than continuing to hope that time
will heal all wounds
this week president obama spoke
powerfully about the need to help solve
the main street credit crisis
so businesses can create jobs and he
spoke about the role tarp might play in
that mission
i look forward today to hearing in more
detail about those plans
and like the chair and my colleagues i'm
very pleased to see you here today and
thank you for your
attention to the panel
thank you mr silver superintendent
neiman good morning mr secretary
yesterday morning our panel issued a
report analyzing the overall
effectiveness of tarp
in a comprehensive year-end review and
while the report criticized several of
tarp's shortcomings to date
it also gave a large share of credit to
the treasury department
and to congress and in my opinion to the
fed and the fdic
for the achievement of the primary
objectives of the esa
tarp's primary primary objectives were
to restore financial stability
and liquidity and this has largely been
achieved as the report stated
and i elaborated in my additional views
this reflection is critically important
so that the american public
can fully appreciate the depth of the
crisis
and how the treasury's multi-prong
response stabilized
not only the financial sector but also
avoided
a dramatic worsening if not collapse
in the real economy but congress
also charged treasury with using tarp
funds in a manner to preserve home
ownership
in addition to promoting jobs and
economic growth
and we are now entering perhaps the most
critical stage of treasury's foreclosure
prevention program
hundreds of thousands of mortgage
modifications in their final
in their trial phase are at risk of not
converting to permanent modifications
because servicers are not obtaining
adequate supporting documentation from
homeowners
the majority of the homeowners in these
trials are in fact making their modified
monthly payments but they will soon be
in danger of elimination from the
program
and will again face foreclosure as their
trial period expires
with documentation still deemed
insufficient
i am sure you agree that neither
homeowners nor
our financial system can afford a trip
back to square one
i look forward to reviewing these and
other issues with you this morning and
again i thank you for your time with us
this morning thank you mr neyman
um i want to note that we are missing
our fifth and newest panelist uh mark
mcwaters
who joined the panel by appointment last
night
he can't be with us today because he has
the flu
so we are sorry and we wish him
well soon as you can see mr secretary
we have kept our remarks brief so that
we will be able to
uh have the maximum amount of time for
questions and answers
so i would ask that you keep your
remarks to five minutes
mr secretary thank you thank you
chairman
uh warren members of the committee of
the oversight committee and thanks for
the option to come before you're going
to testify about this important
set of policy issues facing the country
more than a year ago as you
noted we face one of the most severe
financial crises in the past century
a deep economic contraction and we've
now begun to turn this around
confidence in the stability of the
financial system in the security of
american savings has improved
dramatically credit is flowing again the
economy is now growing
borrowing costs have fallen businesses
have raised
substantial capital from private markets
housing prices have stopped falling in
many parts of the country
and job losses have slowed at a pace
that is more consistent with stronger
recoveries
than weaker recoveries however this is a
very tough economy
and households and businesses still face
very significant challenges
unemployment of course is very very high
commercial real estate losses weigh
heavily on many small banks
impairing their ability to extend new
loans credit is tight for many small
businesses
foreclosures driven now principally by
unemployment are very high
today i want to outline our strategy to
address these challenges going forward
and how we're going to wind down and
ultimately exit the tarp
there are four elements of the strategy
first we will terminate and wind down
the emergency programs that were put in
place at the peak of the crisis that
were necessary to break the back of this
financial panic
in september we shut down the money
market guarantee program
which earned taxpayers 1.2 billion
dollars we've effectively shut down now
the capital purchase program
under which the majority of tarp
investments in banks were made
second we will limit new commitments
under this program in 2010
to three areas housing small banks
and credit markets for consumers and
small businesses
for housing we're going to continue to
work to mitigate foreclosures
for responsible american homeowners as
we take the steps necessary to continue
to help stabilize the financials to the
housing market
for small businesses we've recently
launched initiatives to provide capital
to small and community banks to commit
to increase lending to small businesses
and we are reserving additional funds
for additional efforts to facilitate
small business lending
and finally we're going to continue to
support the securities markets that are
necessary
for um for credit flows to consumers and
small businesses
third beyond these limited new
commitments we will not use remaining
eesa these are tarp funds unless
necessary to respond to an immediate and
substantial threat
to our economy stemming from financial
stability a determination that i will
only make after consulting with the
president and the chairman of the
federal reserve board
and submitting written notification to
congress
fourth we will continue to reduce our
financial stake in banks
and manage our down our other
investments we'll we will keep the
government out of the business decisions
of these companies and we will exit from
our investments as soon as is practical
and return ownership to private hands
this strategy requires
a limited temporary extension of the
authority provided by the congress under
the
emergency economic stabilization act it
would be irresponsible to do otherwise
the expected costs of tarp have fallen
dramatically while we are extending the
program
we do not expect at this point to deploy
more than 550 billion dollars
in total we also expect up to 175
billion dollars in repayments from banks
by the end of next year substantial
additional payments thereafter
and as a result we now expect that the
ultimate cost of tarp will be at least
200 billion dollars less
than was projected as recently as the
august mid-session review of the
president's budget
we now expect to make not lose but to
make money on the 245 billion dollars of
investments in
banks we estimate that the tarp programs
for banks will yield a positive return
of over 19 billion dollars
indeed banks have already repaid more
than 116 billion dollars in investments
the stress test of the major financial
institutions helped accelerate
repayments by providing markets with the
transparency and the confidence
necessary for banks to be able to raise
capital from private sources
these programs as you know have
generated significant income roughly 15
billion dollars which have been used
already to help pay down our nation's
fiscal obligations
of course we do not expect all tarp
investments to generate positive returns
it's unlikely that we will be repaid for
all of our investments in aig
gm and chrysler but even there the
outlook 2 has improved
and you'll see new estimates in the
report we're issuing today
we're going to continue to manage tarp
in a transparent and accountable manner
earlier this morning treasury published
the first annual or maybe some time
today i'm not sure it's out yet
published the first annual financial
statements for this program
these statements discussed in great
detail the operations the impact the
expected cost of the program
gao provided an unqualified opinion of
those statements included there were no
material weaknesses in internal controls
and this is a notable achievement for
the men and women that have helped
put in place this very complicated very
important program in a very short period
of time
let me just end by emphasizing as you
did the importance that we continue to
work to reinforce the process of repair
in our financial system it is absolutely
essential to try to make sure we
establish a strong recovery
that will put americans back to work and
it is very important
because of the consequences created by
the actions necessary to put out this
financial fire
that congress moved to adapt a strong
and comprehensive package of financial
reforms
and i am encouraged by the progress
we've seen today
there's a lot of challenges ahead in
getting a strong package in place
i know you've played a very helpful role
in trying to help bring some thoughtful
insight to those choices and i hope
you'll continue to work with us to help
make sure we have a strong package of
reforms in place
as quickly as possible thank you thank
you mr secretary
so let's start with with your statement
uh you say as part of the extension that
you want to focus
any new spending on housing small banks
and supporting credit to consumers
let me small businesses let me focus on
the small business initiative
um i understand the importance of the
initiative this is the one
uh part of uh tarp that may have a
direct effect
on unemployment or maybe the most uh
easily traced effect on unemployment and
that is if small businesses can borrow
money
uh then they'll be able to stay in
business they'll be able to keep their
employees or hire more employees
so i understand the importance of this
and applaud that approach
but my concern is that last spring
treasury launched the talf program to
stimulate small business lending i
think it was not a success later
treasury announced a program to purchase
up to 15 billion dollars in
securities backed by sba loans
and i believe it's the case that so far
treasury has not
spent a single dollar under that program
and
two months ago treasury announced a
third program to support small business
lending
by providing low-cost capital to
community banks and
as i understand it so far nothing has
happened
so you know it's not news to anyone that
small business lending is important
small businesses are closing every day
but treasury has now announced three
plans
and clearly has not gotten the job done
what's what's going to be different now
mr secretary
let me just start by saying the economy
would not be growing today without tarp
unemployment would be dramatically
higher today without the actions we took
to help stabilize the financial system
and open up the markets that were so
broken let me walk through those
specific programs you pointed out to get
small business lending going again you
know small banks small business you know
they depend on banks overwhelmingly for
credit
and small banks provide about half the
credit small businesses get from the
banking system as a whole
small banks are among the most affected
still by the challenges facing the
economy as a whole many of them
are going to need more capital those
that need more capital are cutting back
on lending and commitments and as you
said that's affecting small businesses
and our judgment to address this
requires
a set of different approaches we
actually have been quite successful in
bringing liquidity back to the
securities markets that are important
for small business lending the tal
program has actually been very helpful
that's one reason why small business
sba loans have increased so much the sba
program providing temporarily higher
guarantees lower fees
is also helping although those programs
are small in total magnitude
but for this to work we have to make it
possible for banks to come
get capital from the government so they
can support more lending
banks are have been very reluctant to
come
and the reason the seven day program
referred to has not yet been launched is
because
the institutions necessary to make that
work have been very reluctant to come
and do business with the government and
they're concerned that if they come
they will be stigmatized and they will
be subject to the risk of
conditions in the future that might make
it harder for them to run their
businesses
so if we're going to be effective in
dealing with this we have to find some
way to
mitigate both the stigma of coming and
the fear of
changes in the future rules of the game
that are going to apply to them
that's going to something we cannot do
on our own it's going to require some
help from congress
to help deal with those basic concerns
but i think you're right to say that
unless banks have access to capital this
is going to be a harder problem to solve
but let me just follow up though mr
secretary because i'm afraid i'm a
little bit confused here
you were talking about small banks as
the most effective
uh lenders to small businesses and we
know this to be true
they're about halfway through half
lending half that's right lending to
small businesses um
but i thought you started by saying you
were going to terminate and wind down
the capital
purchase program and then i thought i
just heard you say you were talking
about putting more capital
into small banks i'm just a little
confused on this
again the um the emergency programs that
were necessary to break the back of the
panic
and the capital programs for large banks
we're now confident we can wind down and
put out of their misery
but as you said the president announced
a program for capital for small
community banks
a few months ago we're going to that's
important we're going to preserve that
and we're exploring ways to build on
that
but for it to work chairman
we need to make sure make it more
comfortable for banks to be willing to
come
let me just though if i can pinpoint how
can it be
that we could manage to put hundreds of
billions of dollars into the hands of
very large financial institutions in
what was effectively a matter of days
and
14 months in tarp we're still talking
about trying to figure out how to put
much much smaller amounts of money into
very small financial institutions
it's not complicated but just let's go
back a little bit
we actually gave did not give the large
banks a choice because it was necessary
for the country
that they have capital put in right away
but hold on just as just
maybe say but but uh small banks
and we made the capital quite
attractively priced as many of you
pointed out
but they are reluctant to come they
don't want to come to business the
government they think it's a sign of
weakness not strength
even though capital is the best way to
help get lending going again
they're reluctant and so let me just
make sure that nothing about us or our
willingness to do it and we as you as
you said we've tried
quite creatively many different ways to
design these things to make it more
attractive but we can't force them to
come
so so your statement here today is the
reason we're having a problem with small
business lending is that you're making
the money available to the small banks
and they just won't come back
that is one that is one of the problems
and is absolutely a central problem
in the in this area the basic credit
crunch you see
across many small businesses across the
country today
is partly as a result of banks pulling
back who don't have capital
to solve that it's not the only thing
you can do but you solve that banks have
to be willing to come get capital
all right thank you mr secretary um mr
amkins
uh okay thank you ma'am chairman uh well
i uh well
i salute uh you very much for uh
producing an
audit um of the tarp program i think
that's great and something that uh
we've been uh obviously expecting and
that's
that's super so look forward to seeing
that later today
um i guess again i disagree with you as
far as how
important uh tarp was uh for the
situation the economy today that is this
basically the cinequan of uh of where we
are with our
meager recovery and whatnot it's hardly
any way an approbation of the program
um but i i want to focus on with all
this talk
uh from the white house and and
elsewhere about um
you know job creation initiatives coming
out of tarp and things like this
what troubles me is um you know what
sort of parameters are you going to put
around this when you're talking about
injecting money into small banks that
are not really troubled but you're doing
it for some other reason
i think you're very much drifting away
from the intent of congress
and passing esa and i wonder how are you
going to analyze this
and come to these determinations
tarp was essentially about credit
recognizing that there is no growth
without credit
the banking system is critical to the
provision of credit
what we've designed for small banks for
community banks for small to help get
small business lending going again
securitization markets opening up
housing more stable
are central to the basic objectives of
tarp
and fully consistent with the authority
that congress provided us okay well i i
guess one thing i want to disagree with
is that issa was probable was enacted
in a crisis atmosphere of where people
were afraid that banks are going to go
under
we're not afraid that community banks
are going to go under and obviously
well i mean maybe we are i mean it
depends on what's going to happen
in the future which is i assume why
you're you're keeping um
tarp alive to to react but uh
but your rationale of injecting money
into them in order to spur a lending
is not a rationale of keeping them from
going under
no i wouldn't i wouldn't say it quite
that way again uh
capital is critical for lending without
capital
lending will decline but that means that
a viable business
that has good demand for its products
will not be able to grow the risk is
its oxygen will be deprived and it will
risk
failure have to cut back on but you're
talking about the business
that the the length the lending that's
that's why power
right that's why you try to talk about
the bank yeah no exactly so but again
banks are critical to that they're not
the only thing but they're critical to
that
and you know if you're a if you're a
small business and you were unlucky in
your choice of bank
and your bank got exposed to a bunch of
commercial real estate exposure
that bank's gonna cut back on your
credit you're gonna have to cut back on
payroll and employment
and it takes time to find out our bank
particularly in a system so traumatized
by the crisis
but well i think part of that too is
examiners and other people who are
um through their scrutiny and there's
this is a natural human reaction to
overreact to
exactly right and to ask questions that
maybe need to be asked but
through that sort of process it then
causes
banks to uh recoil a bit and not be so
ready to lend
you're right about that as commissioner
neiman knows this is a very important
balance to get right and you're exactly
right to say what happens
in recessions after financial booms is
everybody tends to overact the other way
banks may pull back more than this
rational
and supervisors may tend to overreact so
we've been
these are independent supervisors
independent of the treasury right but
we've been
uh encouraging the supervisors to try to
provide some
more balance and the guidance they give
to examiners across the country so they
don't overdo it they issued some
guidance on commercial real estate
lending valuation standards a few weeks
ago
i think that's very helpful they're
looking at additional steps and you're
right to emphasize the importance of
trying to
lean against overreaction by supervisors
okay
well um so i want to go back to then
evidently you all have decided that gmac
deserves some more
funds from no no no we um gmac is part
of the institutions we put through the
stress test early in the spring
okay uh as for many institutions we
identified a significant capital
need and for all those institutions we
said if you do not go raise capital from
the private markets if you're unable to
we will put capital into you because
it's important to the stability of the
system
so the only thing ahead for gmac is what
we committed to do back then
and i think actually the ultimate
estimates will be a little lower than we
anticipated back in
back in june i think when we were
apparently you've decided to inject more
capital
no not no not actually somewhat less
than we actually
estimated in june but the but the more
recent round where they've come back
no it's uh it's just a i know it's uh
just when
june we when we released the uh
estimates in the stress test the
estimated capital needs for these
institutions
we gave them a period of time to go out
and raise capital from the private
markets
overwhelmingly banks were able to do
that in fact it's much better than that
because you see private investors
wanting to come in increase their stakes
in
banks across the country now allowing
the taxpayer
to get out of those investments gmac was
it was never going to be possible for
gmac
they're in a uniquely difficult
situation all we're doing is committing
to
put the capital we committed to do back
in in june probably at a slightly lower
level than we thought back in june
i'll follow up later thank you
thank you mr silvers
mr secretary when
tarp was an act when the isa was enacted
and tarp began
my read of the statute was that the
purpose of tarp
was not to rescue particular
institutions
um even particular firms it was
it was to preserve the system and
for the purpose and the statute was was
i think pretty clear about this
not because the system was a thing of
beauty or because of
our particular concern for again those
businesses but because of the role the
financial system played in providing
the the resources necessary for the real
economy to function
in that regard and stop me if i've got
it wrong
in that regard it seems to me that you
appear to be identifying you and the
and the president appear to be
identifying uh
that uh aspects of this system continue
not to be working adequately and
continue to need more support
particularly small business
credit am i am i reading your own words
back at you correctly
exactly there has been a dramatic
improvement
in the overall stability and functioning
of the u.s financial system
but parts of the system are still very
damaged and broken
i'll mention just three
housing markets are still overwhelming
dependent on
the temporary programs put in place by
the government
commercial real estate financing still
very difficult as you would expect
with an economy coming through such a
large basic adjustment
and there is a significant risk of us of
credit crunch across
small businesses in part because of the
small banks that are still somewhat
exposed to the risk of losses ahead
i don't really know anybody who look at
our system today and not say that those
parts of our system are still
significantly impaired and it's not a
surprise given the
scope of the damage caused by the crisis
there is a very strong economic case
to use the authority provided and it was
perfectly consistent with the objectives
of the authority
to continue to work to that but that's
not the only reason we're extending dr
silvers as you understand which is that
we still need to keep in reserve some
ability
to respond if we were to face again a
serious escalation of systemic concern
it would be deeply irresponsible and
prudent
at this stage only a year into this
recovery process
only three months after we have the
first period of growth
to stand back and walk away from those
challenges ahead that would leave
the taxpayer at much greater risk of
future losses ultimate cost of the
program would go up
not down that's why that's why we've
judged it with prudent to put in place
this limited qualified extension
now if i may pick up on your exchange
with the chair
um there are in
under the tarp two types of programs
really you have
programs where capital has been provided
to firms who are then tarp recipients
and you have programs where tarp funds
have been injected into markets
in in ways such as the tauf and the
p-pip
in ways in which the various private
parties that may touch those funds are
not actually tarp recipients
is is that a fair characterization of of
the
of one way of understanding the two
the range of programs you have that's
right programs for individual
institutions the institutions are tarp
recipients
although as you said they're not for the
benefit the institutions they're because
of the
importance for the system programs that
are about market market-wide support
to capital market securities markets uh
are designed differently
now in light of the concern that you
stated that
small banks have with receiving tarp
money which i which i find
particularly the issue of reputational
risk which i find an understandable
concern
and i'm not sure how congressional
action could change that
in light of that and in light of the
your description
of the small business problem as a
market problem
not a there's not a firm it's not a
particular firm that's a that's weak
here that's the issue
in light of that um are you considering
taking the
the the market support approach
uh rather why not take the market
support approach rather than the firm
support approach in the small business
area
our view from the beginning is you have
to work on both channels of credit
you have the bank channel and you have
the capital markets and you need both
if you can make the capital market
channel work better it creates
competition
for banks it might pull the banks out of
their concern and uncertainty
uh you need both the work but
these are small business credits they're
very small loans
the capital markets were never going to
be provided everything in the past would
not have been
the significant providers in the future
so you have to work on both
my time is running out so i just want to
be clear what i'm saying to you
the the the i'm not suggesting that you
can have a public capital market
solution here i'm suggesting that that
that that if you want to move this money
to uh small business quickly uh that
that both from the perspective of
getting the banks involved without
having
making them into tarp recipients and
from the perspective of
of tapping small bank expertise
that you should be looking at structures
that uh
that move money and and thirdly to avoid
the problem that's been
present in tarp from day one of handing
money to banks and not knowing what it
what use is made of it
that the right way to do this is to do
this through a conduit
that moves tarp money more or less
directly to small firms
with banks as a as a manager of the
process
rather than as an intermediary i
generally agree with you
and i think the most promising ideas out
there lie in that realm
banks still need to have risk on the
table
uh no i'm glad to because we don't think
the government and we couldn't do it
through tarp
be in the business of providing loans
directly to businesses
thank you superintendent neiman thank
you i'd like to come back to the
foreclosure mitigation program over the
last
few weeks there's been a lot of media
focus on the 25
of those individuals who are in trial
mods uh
and who are who are not current on those
trial mods in fact
some may not even have made the first
payment i'd like to focus though on the
75 percent
of those borrowers who are making
payments in a timely fashion
and for them january 1 of this new
coming year will not only bring in a new
year but will also be a fateful day for
almost 400 000 homeowners
whose trial modification period expires
most of these homeowners have made at
least three months of timely payments in
some cases four or five
uh or even greater as required under the
program
however less than half of these
homeowners have submitted all the
required
documentation and by some estimates and
i've talked
to some of the largest servicers uh
directly
half of this group the group that has
submitted all their documents
have yet to have their documentation
decisioned or validated by the servicer
now given these numbers that i've stated
it looks
as if possibly over 75 percent of the
homeowners
who have demonstrated a willingness and
ability
to make timely payments on their trial
mods may be eliminated
from their program and once again facing
foreclosure
now you have recognized the urgency of
this situation by implementing swat
teams at the largest institutions among
other efforts to engage homeowners and
servicers to facilitate both the
submission
of documents by uh borrowers and the
validation of that documentation by the
servicers
so fundamentally my question is does
this expected low conversion rate
imply that the original documentation
standards
are not set correctly and are too
onerous
or do you think that the standards are
correct and any liberal
liberalization would impact the
integrity of the program
uh well as you said we're working on
this on many many fronts we've taken a
careful look about whether we can
streamline the documentation
requirements to help address this
we put we try to mobilize huge amount of
resources to make sure services are
processing these
and convert to permanent mods as quickly
as possible working very closely with
counseling agencies across the country
so they can help do a better job of
helping people benefit from a permanent
modification
and i think we're going to be able to
make substantial progress in the area
although there's a lot of challenge in
here
i just want to emphasize though what
we've achieved so far
almost three-quarters of a million
americans now are benefiting from
modification programs that reduce their
monthly payments
dramatically on average 550 a month
six thousand dollars a year that is a
meaningful
amount of support for income for some of
the people hurt most by this crisis
now we want those mods to be permanent
made permanent
and banks will not get a dollar from the
treasury
unless they convert to permanent mods
and we are using
a tremendous amount of force and
persuasion to try to make sure
we get those conversion rates up to a
reasonable level
but if those uh and i agree with you
those uh reductions monthly payments are
significant
but if at the end of the year this first
group cannot convert to permanent
modifications they will lose
those monthly payments and now be faced
with the same situation
uh being offered as a non-hemp mod by
the servicer which will likely increase
those
payments or foreclosure actions
proceeding so are you considering
extending again the opportunity for the
trial modification so that borrowers who
have not had documentation
validated we're going to work very hard
to avoid the outcome you described we
have a huge stake in trying to make sure
this program
get reaches as many eligible homeowners
as possible and benefit in real economic
terms from this program
and uh we we're not there yet
but i think we're going to be able to
make substantial progress okay uh
we look forward to some of your
performance numbers being issued today
and i know
i think we assume today and you know one
of the virtues in these the numbers we
lay out is you can see
performance service or by servicer
everybody can look and see how many
eligible homeowners are they reaching
uh and you know a number of these need
to get their numbers up they just need
to get them up they need to do a better
job
and they have the ability to do that
there are two other big issues about
will and effort there are certainly two
other big issues
around both negative equity and
unemployment you mentioned
unemployment in in your opening remarks
i appreciate
their response from uh mr allison in in
as a follow-up to our last testimony to
review some of the promos
proposals that i have been promoting for
quite some time
uh with regard to emergency mortgage
assistance programs
and i look forward and thank you all for
agreeing to
to meet separately on those issues
well you're right that those are two
areas where there's a lot of ideas out
there ways we can help
modify this program and you're also
right to emphasize that this
program was not designed and this is a
conscious choice we made
not to start with deep principle
reduction and we made that choice
because
we thought it would be dramatically more
expensive for the american taxpayer
harder to justify create much greater
risk of unfairness
and our program was not designed to do
that our program though
is doing what it was designed to do
which is reaching
many many people across this country
with very substantial reductions in
monthly payments
and we were always looking at ways to
try to help make sure this program
reaches people we can we can reasonably
reach
thank you my time's expired uh if i
could mr secretary i'll just pick right
up on that point and that is
uh the deliberate decision not to deal
with negative equity
because it's created an irony in the uh
against the backdrop of a subprime
mortgage crisis that started with
zero down loans excuse me and hundred
percent financing
we now are creating modified loans
supported by the united states
government that have
110 percent loan to value ratios 120
loan to value ratios 125 percent loan to
value ratios
we have no experience with long-term
payment of deeply underwater mortgages
but the little bit of data that we do
have available
about even modestly underwater mortgages
suggests that over the long term second
only to the question of affordability of
the payment
long-term uh being underwater on a
mortgage
means that people are unlikely to
continue to make their mortgage payments
so so i'm i want to push back on this a
little bit
are we creating a program in which we're
talking about
potentially spending 75 billion dollars
to try to modify people into mortgages
that will reduce the number of
foreclosures
in the short term but just kick the can
on down the road
so that we'll be looking at an economy
with elevated
mortgage foreclosures not just for a
year or two but
for many years how do you how do you
deal with that problem mr secretary
our program reduces the basic overall
obligation these mortgages it does not
increase it
and we have people in these programs
with very very high ltvs
very substantial amounts of negative
equity able to qualify and it does bring
down the overall burden
i'm sorry are you saying that you are
doing principal reductions no but the
the change in payment schedule does
reduce
the basic value of the obligations in
the mortgage
but but i i think that it's more helpful
to me to say it this way
i think you're right to point out the
huge problem the amount of negative
negative equity across the system
presents for us the question is
is what to do about it that's the hard
thing what is driving this now
principally
the whole foreclosure crisis across the
country now is really driven by what's
happened unemployment
and what's happened to income of
americans
and i think our judgment is
the best things we can do now to help
mitigate that risk
is to help get the economy growing again
bring unemployment down as quickly as we
can put people back to work
and continue to make sure we're
providing overall stability of the
housing market
and we've seen actually better results
on prices and expectations about future
prices than many of us expected
we've brought interest rates down to a
very low level so the houses are much
more affordable now
and housing demand is actually picking
up a bit
the question is not what are what you
described as a problem you've been
eloquent and persuasive about the
scale-up problem the question is whether
in addition to those actions we should
embark now on a program where
we are at what would be very very
dramatic additional cost to taxpayer
uh helping relieve people of that
obligation and the problem in doing that
apart from its expenses
the basic sense of fairness and what it
does to incentives in the future
now but i think you've got you're asking
the right question the question is just
do we have a solution that's fair
well you know i i really would like to
push back you you talk about relieving
the the homeowner let's keep in mind
this is about
whether or not the investors in these
mortgages some of whom made substantial
profits during the glory days
should be required to take the losses
when the mortgages that they invested in
turn out not to be worth
nearly so much as they had promised you
know
what it means well one means would be
through bankruptcy which
doesn't cost the american taxpayer any
money that would be one means
another that i am deeply concerned about
is the extent to which the current
programs that treasury advances sends a
signal
to investors and mortgages and the
signal is
sit on the sidelines you know uh there's
no reason to come to the table and
negotiate these mortgages
uh you can wait for the us treasury to
offer a bribe to get you to the table to
do what should have been
in your interest to begin with we all
understand
that foreclosures don't just destroy
value for homeowners they destroy value
for the investors themselves
and yet investors are hanging back they
are not engaging in rational write-downs
that would keep a good stream of
payments coming from these businesses
instead holding out for larger streams
of payment and holding out for help
from your treasury department well i
don't think i quite agree with that
you're right that bankruptcy reform is
one option that might help change the
incentives a bit and you've been an
eloquent advocate of those reforms and
as you know the president united states
did propose
and was supportive of but congress was
unwilling to act in part because of
concerns is it would make it harder
for capital to come back into the
banking system and help support
improvement in housing markets that have
broader returns that's a judgment the
congress congress considered
and chose a different strategy
i don't agree that the programs are in
place are are working against this
process repair that you're
we all support i think actually they're
helping and actually we're seeing
quite a lot of new interests and
willingness
in investors and people hold these
things to renegotiate and write down
we're seeing much more of that than you
saw before and i think that's
encouraging i don't think we're
deterring that you know i i have to say
mr secretary i lived through a big
housing
boom and bust down in the southwest
during the late 1980s
in fact i lost money on the house we had
to sell during the bust
but the government didn't step in and
help
in the same way the lenders had to eat
the losses for
bad investments that they got involved
in and so did the homeowners
this was not a question of taxpayer
support there
this this crisis as you know and and i
think you understand
is nothing like that crisis it's much
more dramatic in its scale and impact
much broader effects on people across
the country
and i don't think there's anything from
that basic crisis in the past that would
have been helpful now
you could one could take the view that
it was a mistake to try to give
americans the ability to see a
substantial reduction in their monthly
payments
and therefore improve the odds they get
to keep their house i don't agree with
that i don't think you do either
i think actually this is a program
that's doing quite well
in delivering a very meaningful
improvement
in the basic financial economic position
as i said almost three-quarters of a
million americans now
and i think it's been part of what has
actually been a quite successful effort
to bring
some modicum of stability to housing
prices much earlier than many people
would have thought
thank you mr secretary i apologize to my
co-panelists
no i apologize to my co-panelist for
running over by two minutes and i'm
going to skip my next round of questions
uh mr atkins oh thank you very much um
and i i actually i think you had some uh
good rationale there and uh with respect
to negative equity
um i think it would be a mistake to
start uh um dumping money into that
i don't know that there's enough money
around to
once you start getting to that in the
issues of fairness and everything else i
grew
on that um i wanted to turn to
uh as far as tarp goes to the exit
that we were talking about earlier that
you alluded to
um the recent capital one warrants
uh auction i i guess you can call that a
success of some sort
um i was wondering how you
foresee this going forward in the future
are you still planning on engaging in
negotiated
price buybacks with tarp banks before
establishing an auction
what is the current view of treasury as
to how you can unwind this
i think it's possible that we're going
to still see a mix of approaches going
forward in part because for many small
banks
and auctions not going to be a realistic
approach but auction is a good approach
for many cases and that gives a way to
let the market determine uh the best
price we think that'll help maximize the
return of the taxpayer
in the recent one you refer to you know
was oversubscribed by i think a factor
of 12.
and uh you know of course the ultimate
test of what these things are worse
our worth is has to be established by
what people are willing to pay for them
so i think it's an approach that um it's
going to deliver better returns than the
alternatives in this case but it won't
be possible for all the institutions in
which the government took warrants
well then so then as we go forward and
you talk about putting money into
all sorts of uh community banks and
others um
what is the approach um how what is
actually the
um the decision-making process of uh
you know how the money goes in and what
is received
by the treasury in return for a myriad
now we're talking about we already have
600 and some
banks that are participants well the
program at its beginning
uh and i was not the secretary of the
treasury then but i think i but i agree
very much with this basic design was
it was designed to make capital
available on the same terms
to all institutions so the same uh
capital that was provided as the largest
institutions
was made available to any other
institution that made similar standards
for eligibility
and uh my predecessor and the
supervisors put in place an elaborate
process for deciding
for determining viability to try to
screen institutions that process remains
in place today
we're going to use that process going
forward we're changing strategy in some
important directions some important ways
we do not believe it's necessary to keep
capital purchase program open for large
institutions
so the remaining programs we're going to
provide that provide capital will be for
institutions below a certain threshold
we're trying to make them design them in
a way that's going to maximize the
chance they go to spur lending
by and make it more likely they come as
a sign of strength not a sign of
weakness
as we just discussed with the with the
chairman but we're going to leave in
place a basic viability standard to make
sure that we're not supporting
non-viable institutions
so how do you determine that well the
supervisors have a process in which they
look at supervisor raising
all sorts of all sorts of measures of
rating and financial strength and you
know there's nothing as you know this is
a highly imperfect process but it's
better than the alternatives
okay well then um and then to go back
i'm sorry to go back to
gmac again so i understand at least in
the call that i
um listen in on um that there that there
is a negotiation going on
and i guess i want to try to understand
how i mean who is actually the decision
maker is it
uh assistant secretary allison or is it
you as far as determining
you know under what terms uh further
extension of credit
is given um viewing the particular
um facts the financial terms will be as
defined in the other programs they're
not differentiated financial terms the
question ahead is really
what uh plan for restructuring
the new board and management of this
firm embark on
we want to be confident that's going to
be provide some basic path to exit and
viability
and what are the incremental capital
needs relative to what was identified
back in june under the stress test
those are the issues ahead okay and so
two of those board members are treasury
picks or or um how much interaction do
you have
uh with people on the board well we have
uh
just about what you'd expect and hope
and not more than you'd fear
in the sense that uh in the sense that
uh again our objectives are
no but i'm not sure what your fears are
our obligation is to make sure again
that
these this institution has in place a
plan for getting back to viability
without government assistance that has a
reasonable prospect of working
we want the new management and board
they're taking a fresh look at that
and we want that to be as strong and
robust as possible at the same time of
course we need to reassess
what the incremental capital needs would
be and that's the process we're
undertaking now
okay my time's up thanks mr silvers
uh mr secretary i'd like to shift in
terms of the wind down discussion to the
large banks which you've mentioned a
couple of times
um my new york times this morning
uh tells me that um something that
i think we all kind of already knew
which is that um city would very much
like to
to return its tarp money city argues
that
they have lots of cash at least that's
an argument they've made
to this panel and that having lots of
cash means they should they should be
able to return the tarp money
i don't have your experience with banks
but that doesn't strike me as exactly
the right argument
i think you're right can you can you
explain to me what the criteria is for
being able to return the money
and and what relevance if any having
lots of cash has
few critical points um one it is a good
thing for the country
that banks are eager to get out of the
investments the government was forced to
put in them
that is healthy necessary desirable
two it is a very good thing for the
country that private investors are
willing to come in and
in effect take the government out of
those positions
we are not prepared to have this money
come back
in a way that would leave the system or
these institutions with inadequate
capital to face their challenges ahead
if we did that
that might seem good near term but it
would be bad for the country as a whole
because it would leave the system with
too little capital
so what we've done is to say
we want you to go out and raise capital
this is that for the
system in general raise capital from the
markets
so you can repay the taxpayer with
interest
and that's what's happening uh mr
secretary
do i have it right that the requirement
is that you should be able to raise the
entirety
of your tarp money that we're not we're
not allowing repayments in stages
is that is that correct uh i don't think
i would say it quite that way and this
is a difficult thing for me to do
because
under the laws of the land the
supervisors are responsible for setting
the terms
of uh exit uh
but surely you know a few things about
about how they're doing
i do know a few things about it and i
have some views on that but the basic
objective is to make sure that
as we exit which we're going to do as
quickly as we can quickly as in prudent
we're leaving the capital position of
the institutions
stronger not weaker very good um in this
regard mr secretary obviously bank of
america has
is now in process um the um
uh it could be a little hard to follow
the
the the state the steps in which they're
doing it um
can you explain are they repaying all of
the tarp money and have they
raised equity capital to do that
repayment
in an amount that is equivalent to both
the tip and the cpp
well i can tell you what the good thing
is that i got a check for 45 billion
dollars
that's nice i'm interested what the
source of funds for that check is
and as you said they went out and raised
a mix of uh it was predominantly common
but i'd be happy to
respond to writing you have the fed
respondent writing with the details of
all right but
actually i think it's out there clearly
in the market
i think the details are all out there
because it should be a public offering
right but it's but
the policy appears to be judging from
what one
reads uh in out in the public uh
the policy appears to be raise all raise
in equity
uh preferred or common all of the money
necessary
to repay not not a portion is that is
that your understanding
uh i think that is generally a desirable
approach because cleaner exit is better
than a staged exit i'm not sure that's
going to be possible
in every circumstance but i think that
again it's a good thing that you want
these institutions are
eager to go out and have private
investors come out and take the
government out
um mr secretary uh andrew ross sorkin
a reporter for the new york times who
judging by his book seems to often know
more than we do
uh has written about the bank of america
repayment
that uh quote uh
watch i'm not going to quote it will
take too long he expresses himself
he said basically two things he said one
the fdic didn't think they should be
allowed to be
to repay and he said too that the reason
why they were so eager to repay
was so that they could increase their
executive compensation that could be
offered to a successor to their current
ceo mr lewis
uh all right can you tell me are those
statements true
uh i don't want to speak to the first uh
i think it'd be inappropriate me to do
that
uh on the second question uh i think
you're absolutely right that the
compensation restrictions that we put in
place for firms that took exceptional
assistance were very tough
restrictions right and and they were
appropriately tough restrictions
and for that reason but for many other
reasons
again because you're going to view it as
stronger in the eyes of the market
if you're an institution without public
capital these banks were eager to come
and repay
and i think we should welcome that
encourage it and i expect to see
substantial more of that ahead
i'm not going to press you to reveal
perhaps what you feel as a
viewer as a confidence but it strikes me
that it's a matter of deep concern
if the fdic doesn't agree with allowing
the repayment
because the bank is too weak my time's
about to expire so i'm going to express
a further thought rather than
uh pressing you uh on this
the the uh
effectively the the the strength of
treasury and the regulators uh uh
sense that reap that premature repayment
when these banks are weak
is bad for the country uh that is an
extremely important thing right
not and we would not allow that or
support it right and and i want to
encourage and bolster your
your uh your viewpoint there and i would
be concerned
deeply concerned uh if those kinds of
considerations were overridden
by no matter how well-meaning any desire
to increase people's executive pay
actually again we would not support that
and i think that the agreement
you saw reaching that context
strengthens
the institution very substantially the
best test of that of course is what
happens going forward
but that private investors come in and
willing to put substantial amounts of
capital
is a sign of confidence and strength
superintendent niemann thank you
now we all acknowledge uh the
crisis uh that was avoided by the uh the
the impressive efforts of the
multi-prong efforts
by the administration and other agencies
and we hear
words uh some of which you used this
morning uh last week chairman bernanke
characterized what we avoided as a
global financial meltdown
magnitude unseen for generations
a second great depression cataclysm
you know as i stated in in my opening
i think it really is imperative uh that
the the american public
understand the uh linkage
to the real economy as well as what
really was avoided
could you share with us uh
your descriptions of the sequencing of
what could have played out with the
failures of
a large interconnected firms and and the
direct linkage to the real economy
because i think that really is at the
heart
of of of of assessing the the
effectiveness of the program
in september of last year for the first
time i think in almost
uh 70 years americans across the country
were starting to take their money out of
banks banks that were strong no
connection to the weaknesses in the
subprime crisis
because they were scared about the
security of their savings
you saw economic activity around the
world
come to a stop markets froze around the
world
the value of american savings fell by
more than 40 percent
people were faced with the prospect
having to work 10 years longer than they
expected
because of the loss of value their
savings you saw again millions and
millions of americans
lose their jobs thousands of businesses
fail did not need to fail
deeply unfair and unjust deep damage to
the basic confidence of americans in the
fairness and justice
of our system deep loss of confidence
around the world
in our basic financial stewardship of
this country
it is not something that is about a set
of individual institutions or wall
street it is about the basic fabric of
confidence in america
basic security americans have in their
future when you
when you allow that to to um to suffer
so much damage
as you're seeing it takes a huge amount
of time to repair that basic damage
so financial crises are unjust and
traumatic because they cause
deep damage to people who were careful
and prudent had nothing to do with the
crisis
and the scars that creates are long
lasting and
we are going to live with for a long
time
the challenge of trying to repair that
damage
thank you for that uh you know one issue
that is also addressed in
our report issued yesterday are issues
around moral hazard
uh and we have debate among the panel
itself as to to the extent that tarp
increased the risks and costs of moral
hazard
as i i set out i think moral hazard was
a
was almost built into the fact of the
the emergency efforts
the the fact is will government always
be there i think you just explained
the criticality of why the government
had to step in
and uh and why i think your position
which i
also agree with is that to address
the moral hazard we have to address too
big to fail and that is an imperative
for our congress which they are debating
currently
uh i strongly agree that the need for a
systemic
regulator and a resolution authority but
i'd like
your uh you know uh views on whether we
should be
in effect allowing institutions to grow
to such
largeness and complexity to be
characterized as too big to fail
and isn't it time to engage in a debate
in this country now that we all
recognize that this
the safety net that there are that there
is for institutions
the benefits that financial institutions
particularly
depository institutions have from fdic
programs from
fed as a lender bank last resort isn't
it a time
to debate uh what we want our
institutions to be
are they social utilities that should be
able to engage
in speculative and high risk activities
i think i agree with everything you said
uh the tragic choice in financial crises
is
to solve the problem put out the fire
protect the innocent
limit damage you have to act
you can't sit there and hope it's going
to burn stuff out and if you worry about
moral hazard too much
as we as you saw this is the story of
the first 18 months of this crisis
you can see enormous pain and damage
and what it takes to clean that up will
cause much more moral hazard
so if you care about moral hazard you
have to care about having
basic protections to prevent panics from
spreading
it's the paradox people tend to think
that if you care about moral hazard
you should be against the fire station
but if you don't have the ability to act
as you saw the damage is so sweeping and
traumatic
governments will have to do so much more
on such a broader scale with much
greater cost of future incentives
so it's a good case for emergency
authority absolutely and we are having a
debate about
too big to fail and we have proposed a
sweeping set of new authorities and
constraints
that reduce the risk that banks in the
future take on so much risk
that they could imperil the system and
we're proposing a
an ability to allow them to fail
with less damage to the system and less
risk the taxpayer as a whole it's very
important to have and we're having that
debate now in the congress
which is very welcome thank you mr
atkins
well that's great i wanted to actually
pick up that thread so
uh this is a good segue um to really
talk about ways in which going forward
now with the remaining
months of tarp you know you intend to
use them
um you know my friend from the united
auto workers here has been uh
very uh of course i'm supportive of uh
tarp because i guess 80 billion dollars
went into gm
chrysler and gmac and we heard uh uh
paul yes i don't work for the united
author well i don't know who you were
talking about
but uh or in the socialization of the
small business landing which you were
suggesting but
i guess one thing i wanted to focus on
was
um the as far as
treasury's use of the funds going
forward and how it's going to be
allocated i think that has implications
you mentioned the
the proposals administration's proposals
for um
new statutory authority for uh
resolution
and for a systemic risk regime um
and basically i guess the way i view the
uh the resolution authority is really
just a codification of tarp for years to
come
because of the flexibility it builds in
and
when we view how treasury has
interpreted
a tarp over the last year and and now by
the sounds of it if we're talking about
job creation
or whatever else is coming out
from the administration exactly what
sort of uses
are you going to put these funds to
because you've said
sort of both sides now you want to keep
someone reserved you want to put some
in the community banks and i guess i
don't really understand
let me start with the um let me start
with a job creation question
and let me try and say it as simply as i
can
because of what we've been able to
achieve in terms of stability in the
system
there are at least 200 billion dollars
in lower costs ahead
that because of because we've achieved
so much improvement in stability and do
not now believe
it's going to be necessary to suspend a
substantial amount of resources and
because the expected value of these
investments has gone up very
substantially
those savings reduce the budget
deficit they go to reduce the budget
deficit
you cannot use tarp to fund an
infrastructure program
you can't use tarp to provide a tax cut
to small businesses you can't use tarp
to incent
green energy efficiency products those
are choices congress gonna have to make
what we've done though
because of the careful financial
stewardship of this program
is dramatically reduce the expected
costs
uh much much lower than anybody
anticipated
not just at the beginning of last year
but in august that gives
the congress and the president some
choices to make about how to use those
resources
and they i believe and they'll be a very
strong case for doing that
for using some of those resources to
support targeted
uh measures that can help get job
creation
back more quickly but there's going to
be substantial resource to also reduce
our long-term future deficits
now i want to come back to where you
began though just very quickly
the resolution authority we proposed is
nothing like
a permanent tarp and i want to make this
very clear and i would not support that
for reasons i think you would agree with
what wrestlemania does is
allow the government to in effect
take an institution that has mismanaged
itself to the edge of the cliff
and in effect put it in receivership
and wind it down not save it not give it
a chance for redemption
but to sell and wind it down safely at
less cost the taxpayer
less damage to the public it is not a
chance for redemption
well the problem is though there's so
much flexibility no i don't think so in
fact in fact and
again i i think this is very important
the
the challenge in these things is giving
the government some authority
to contain financial panics that has to
be very very very very very very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very very very very very quickly
right now no it doesn't actually it just
this a very interesting
thing coming into this crisis the united
states of america
president of the united states the only
emergency authority he had to contain
the panic himself
in this case executive branch before
tarp was passed and the
fannie and freddie legislation was
passed was to in effect to clear a bank
holiday and close markets
that was it but that's another tragic a
tragic mistake for the country
no it's actually very limited but the
the panic containing authority
we think we need to limit discretion in
that case well i okay i i think that
um going back then to basically this
goes back to the
issue of tarp as revolving uh revolving
let's talk about that i'd like to talk i
would like to have
a uh opinion from the general counsel of
the treasury
addressing that issue which we have i've
asked for back in september and we
haven't gotten yet
so because i think that is really
germane to what you're talking about as
far as
how much money has been saved and is
going to be reallocated okay
happy to provide that we're at time here
we provide that in many many many times
to many of the
city members of congress that have asked
but happy to cop you on those things
but congress designed this with that
basic feature
it was wise to do it well i read that
statue differently because i disagree
with that i think
uh i think it uh really calls on the
question actually actually there's been
no challenge
from the congresswoman all right
gentlemen
mr silvers yeah
um i'd like to just make an observation
because uh
my colleague mischaracterized whom i
work for i
work for the afl-cio the united auto
workers is a member of the afl-cio
i do not work for the united auto
workers
i don't have that honor
and but i feel very very strongly
about the dignity of people who work
hard physically for a living
and and i think that is often not
properly honored in washington um
mr secretary um
i'd like to uh touch on
come back to the big bank issues
um i'm just confused about something and
perhaps it's just i'm not reading
closely enough but i've
you know we passed notes back and forth
with the staff here and the staff is
confused as well
um bank of america has 45 billion in
tarp
uh in in uh preferred stock with the
government holds 45 billion in preferred
stock bank of america
were held bank of america had a
public offering of 19 billion what is
the source of funds for the remaining
45 billion dollars the federal
government received from bank of america
uh the remain the remainder of the 45
billion
uh well as i said i think that probably
i should do i should give it to you in
writing which i'd be happy to do
there isn't any other equity offering is
there it's a little more complicated
than that okay bulk of it was raising
common equity
it leaves there and this is the
important thing it leaves the capital
position of the institution
stronger than it was before this not
just in the eyes of the supervisors
which is very important and this they
all agreed on
but also in the eyes of the market and
their creditors and that's the ultimate
test but be happy to provide well no
are you saying that andrew ross sorkin's
comment about fdic isn't correct because
you said they all agreed on it
well i i was trying to like stick to my
line which is i'm not going to comment
on the discussion
i believe that it is very important
i know the supervisors believe that it's
important to make sure that as we exit
the institutes are stronger not weaker i
think they share that view
i'm glad they do okay well perhaps mr
sorkin is wrong
um the fact that stronger not weaker
i don't have all the numbers in front of
me i can run them in my head but to what
extent
if any uh are the are the funds
for the for the repurchase of the of the
uh
bank of america preferred uh coming from
uh
from internal earnings uh i don't think
they are
but again i need to go back and give you
the numbers in detail and this stuff but
look let's again focus on the stuff that
is critical to the financial position of
the firm
so the best way to do it is look at
their common equity ratio
to assets before the repurchase
and after that measure which is probably
the most valuable measure of financial
strength
is stronger with repayment not weaker
what i'm concerned about and i think of
the quality let me see another way of
thinking about it
the quality of capital that has the
strongest source of confidence tomorrow
now if it's a common equity ratio of
course it would be stronger because
you're because you they raise common and
paid off preferred that's it that's the
that's the basic uh nature of the
strategy
and it's a good strategy well but but
but but that would of course happen even
if the bulk of the
funds were raised by something other
than a public offering
it concerns me that the basic standard
appears to be a good one which is that
if you want out of tarp you've got to be
able to raise the
the equivalent amount of tarp in tarp
funds of them
in in new and new equity of the tarp
funds you are paying back
that's not quite the standard uh well
let's not explain well explain the
standard then
well again this is really a discussion
you have with the supervisors because
you know under the laws of the land the
supervisors set the turns to repeat
yeah i know but you said they know a
fair amount about it and you're the only
one here today
i don't think it's as complicated as
you're making it it's a simple thing
common equity before repayment
after repayment higher after repayment
it's good for the system
it's not clear to me if the rate if if
the commoner
if if you raised a little bit of common
equity but mostly allowed preferred to
be paid back with cash that comes out of
earnings
that's not i don't think that's right
but again uh i'd be happy to i mean
again i'd be happy to
ask the supervisors i'm sure they'd be
responsive to lay it out in detail in
writing but i think it is in their
market now but again we're happy to
provide an authoritative report on it
i just hope you keep insisting that in
the future
i can't i can't change what you've done
with bank of america but i hope you keep
insisting in the future
that dollar for that you have to be able
to have the strength
to raise the equivalent amount in in in
the public markets
in equity common or preferred that
you're paying back in tar money okay
that's
that's it on time superintendent neiman
i'd like to go back to uh our original
dialogue
regarding supporting small business
lending through expanding
uh capital investments in community
banks and
i uh in my record so strongly supporting
those initiatives uh and i also agree
with your assessment
uh of the reluctance of community
of banks in particular uh to participate
and i think you identified uh the the
primary
reason for that reluctance uh being a
stigma
one way to address that reluctance and
stigma
is to issue those details uh regarding
the
the program uh you know focusing on
eligibility requirements
a criteria for approvals uh details
about the approval process
i think greater transparency in the
program and the program
was announced i believe uh october 19th
so that
we're approaching almost two months
before the details
are issued i i think greater
transparency
a full disclosure of of the eligibility
requirements
uh is there a black box that's going to
determine uh
eligibility uh would go a long way in
addressing those concerns and and
reluctance on the part of the bank so
any further insight on how you intend to
address
those uh concerns of the banking
community as well as any projections as
to when
we may see more details about the
application and approval process
again happy to happy to try to do that
you're a supervisor so you know that
some of this is going to have to be
about judgment too you can't reduce it
to a
a clear simple set of criteria um
it's not just about stigma though again
it's probably the concern about
what future conditions might be how they
might change because as you know they
have changed over time and that that's a
big part of the deterrence
uh you know let's talk about lessons
learned in developing
those details for the program what are
the lessons learned from the large bank
capital investments that can now be
employed to the smaller bank
program i was glad to see that the
outline of the program would include a
detailed
uh lending programs to be submitted as
part of that application as well as
ongoing reporting requirements
we think that would help
i can't tell yet though whether that's
going to be sufficient uh
you know i think you understand you
can't um we don't want to have the
government opposition
forcing banks to lend or meet
quantitative criteria for lending it's
just not a feasible way to do it
particularly with loan demand falling so
much
in the aftermath of recession but we
think it's a promising approach
uh i think as you know we're also
improving substantially the survey we've
put in place
that allow banks to report on how they
use the funds and what actually happened
to different categories of lending and
asset growth
i think that should help too and we're
open to other suggestions
uh that raises another important point
can you share with us
your assessment evaluation of bank
lending
in terms of both originations uh as well
as
uh bank balances uh you have to look at
overall credit to have a good sense of
the risk of credit crunch now
overall credit the price credit has come
down a lot
uh bank lending is still falling for
reasons you all understand
borrowing from the securities markets
for those who have access
is increased very very dramatically on
net
credit is still falling no surprise in
that of course because
in a recession as the economy because
the economy slowed so much
felt contracted so much demand would
fall quite a lot but the pace of decline
is slowing a bit
and if you look at surveys of what
businesses say they're seeing
they now they do not cite credit as the
principal problem they face
mostly what they face is lower demand
for their products going forward
so when we hear about uh banks
maintaining
large uh balances at the federal reserve
earning a spread is that something that
the
the public should be concerned about or
are we looking at
i don't think so i think that's just as
that's just the necessary consequence of
the actions the fed's taking to help
uh frankly bring growth back uh bring
unemployment down
uh and and you know banks are still
somewhat cautious still looking forward
but there is much more capital in
financial today
and the overall system is a much
stronger position to support recovery as
recovery takes hold
there are a bunch of charts in my uh
testimony
that report on these survey-based
measures of credit conditions and i
think they provide some other helpful
indications of the broad trends we see
so i would say dramatically better than
it was quicker than we would have hoped
but still pockets of the country still
very vulnerable to
a uh damaging contraction and credit
okay great thank you um
so mr secretary we're talking a great
deal here about systemic risk and of
course systemic risk is
what we were talking about a year ago
when we got into the business of bailing
out large financial institutions
and particularly with aig
that's why i read the november 17th
report of the special inspector general
uh for the troubled assets relief uh
programs report
as you know he was quite critical of uh
the actions that you took in negotiating
uh with the ultimately with
counterparties
uh for the aig financial instruments
now i i was struck by two quotes in
there
he he says that uh the federal reserve
and treasury officials defended the
rescue of aig on the grounds that the
company's failure quote
posed considerable risk to the entire
financial system and would have
significantly
intensified an already severe financial
crisis
and contributed to a further worsening
of global economic conditions which i
think is
has been the standard story for well
over a year but the report
also states that you told sig tarp
that quote the financial condition of
the counterparties
was not a relevant factor in the
decision
to see to it that goldman sachs and
other counterparties were paid 100 cents
on the dollar
i have to say these two statements
appear to be at odds with each other
let me try to explain please um systemic
risk you know is a
complicated difficult thing to assess
and measure
the risk to the system from aig's
collapse
is not particularly reflected in the
direct effects
on its major counterparties the banks
that bought protection from aig
the direct effects of failure this is
true for lehman too and for all the
other financial affairs of this period
of time
the direct effects of that failure would
not have been particularly significant
what was significant for the system as a
whole was the broader cloud
collateral damage that would have
happened in the event of failure so what
you saw after lehman for example
is a general pullback or a classic run
on
the entire system aig presented exactly
that type of risk
but in some ways a much greater scale
because aig unlike lehman
unlike bear stearns had written a bunch
of different types of insurance products
savings protection vehicles
to the retail community across this
country and around the world
and if those uh if those policyholders
had lost confidence
in the system as a whole then the damage
could have been much greater
so this is it sounds like a um of course
the entire system was at risk
and if the system has collapsed no
institution in the united states around
the world would have been invulnerable
to that collapse
i'm losing the logic here mr secretary
if goldman sachs
could have withstood these losses and
the other only the directions
only the direct effects of that stuff
it's not the right way to
so they still could have paid off all
the parties in turn that they owed money
to this would not have caused goldman
sachs to collapse this would not have
caused the direct counterparties to
collapse
you understand this when you when you
decide
it is necessary to prevent default
you prevent default if aig had not met
its contractual obligations to his
counterparties
it would have defaulted it would have
been downgraded
and the company would have collapsed and
happened to be liquidated in the midst
of the worst financial storm
in generations there was no feasible way
to selectively default on his
counterparties without bringing the
whole thing down
that was the choices mr secretary we did
not step
in and back up all of the counterparties
all of the trades we picked aig
and aig alone
that's not true that's on the dollar
repayments no that's not true
no no that's that's not true at all we
we act you're right to say we acted to
prevent aig's default because
there was no other way to protect the
system from the damage of that
the consequences of preventing
preventing default was aig
met its contractual obligations you
cannot selectively default on
contractual obligations without
courting collapse and downgrade now what
we did terry
that the consequence of what you have
just described then is you are telling
me
that these counterparty obligations
these uh financial instruments that are
bought by very sophisticated parties are
going to be treated effectively
like deposits in checking accounts and
savings absolutely absolutely they ended
up
effectively with 100 on the dollar
government guarantee they did because
because there was which they had never
paid no but
you have to distinguish two things first
of all there is no other way
in the context of that storm to protect
the economy from that failure
now looking forward in the future
we do not want to have a system in which
looking forward this is why we need
resolution authority
a strong package of reforms we do not
want investors in the future
or the firms that these particular firms
to live with the expectation
the government will be there that is the
challenge that's why financial reform is
so necessary now
chairman nothing would have made me
happier in that basic context to have a
different set of choices
but given the laws of the land the
authority we had a tragic mistake for
the country
we had no other choice in that
circumstance yeah i do believe that it
had a choice
until you moved in and that was that
they could pay 90 cents on the dollar at
85 cents on the dollar
80 cents on that i don't understand why
that's so complicated you either
potentially fall
complicated no no terry but it's come
down to the nature of choices
it's you either prevent default because
default would be cataclysmic
or you don't and when you provide when
you prevent a fault
you're doing so they so they can meet
their obligations to everyone they have
contractual obligations too if you
selectively default on any
the thing will come crashing down that
is the consequence of the system we had
going into this crisis that's why we
want to change it that's why i want to
change the system
mr secretary i come from a world of
chapter 11. people default all the time
they negotiate
on their obligations and they do not
bring down the entire that you're
exactly right and you're and you're a
national expert on this basic issue and
that's why
but banks are different aig is
effectively a g was not a bank i
i'm out of time and i've done it to
myself again i i apologize no but this
is but this is good to have can we just
we do it a minute longer it's very
important to have a very important
debate to have fine i think that's fine
go at it mr secretary all my time
go ahead mr secretary and you know this
i know you understand this financial
institutions
the congress is recognized for a long
time need a different type of bankruptcy
regime
than we have for other companies now aig
is not a bank
but in effect it operated as a bank it
borrowed money it operated on leverage
it did not capital to support that
for the same reason we've had in place a
different type of bankruptcy for banks
for many many decades
we need one for complex finances that
operate just like banks
now in bankruptcy you have lots of
choices you can negotiate all sorts of
different treatments in this context
in ways that would be helpful for the
country what we want is a
bank type resolution regime that gives
us the choices
that we've had for banks and for in a
sense quasi bankruptcy in the
netherlands but we did not have that
for complex large financial institutions
and that's what limited our choices well
we may disagree about whether or not we
had it but we would certainly agree
that we do need a system in order to be
able to liquidate large financial
institutions
where we may draw a very sharp
difference
is whether or not we should ever be in
the business of doing that
after the fact and going back and
effectively guaranteeing
transactions with non-bank institutions
you feel the same way
taxpayer dollars just to understand do
you feel the same way about the fdic
guarantees put in place in september
like us because the guarantees again you
would never
ever want a country to be in a position
where you have to do guarantees
temporary effective for whatever price
because
of what as a because of the moral hazard
risk but in a
financial panic there is often
no other way to stem the risk of much
greater damage
to the innocent mr geithner there are
though
real consequences to doing that because
now markets
understand that you may at any point
decide that anyone is large enough and
that their debts should therefore
be backed up by the u.s taxpayer well
said and no one feels more strongly
about that and that is why
even in the midst of this deep crisis we
propose sweeping reforms that would give
us better choices in the future
but not feel more strongly about that
good thank you i apologize to my
fellow panelists mr atkins very uh
fruitful discussion i thought
so and i and i note that uh next month
we'll be
drilling into aig as a topic and so i
look forward to
that as well but i just wanted to turn
back to um
i think part of the problem especially
last year
was predictability transparency
of what the government's actions were
and also
with respect to um uh what uh balance
sheets and other things or
um uh were consisting of and that sort
of made the marketplace itself
uneasy and i think that's part of the
same
thing that i wanted to discuss here now
is the predictability of
of who gets what who does what to whom
and that's what i was trying to refer to
earlier
as far as the auto programs i wasn't
certainly disparaging working man
but there is a huge perception out there
that auto unions
got a great deal out of that
auto rescue package that was negotiated
earlier this year
but that dovetails into the situation
with small businesses that we've been
talking about a lot of the problem in
today's
business environment is an uncertainty
as to what the future holds the
administration is talking about
in congress talking about huge tax
increases you know huge new
expensive health care plan new onerous
environmental regulations that are being
talked about
um and then looming deficits of course
you know far into the future not even
counting
the off balance sheet obligations of the
united states government which some
people have put in a hundred trillion
dollars or more
so nobody basically can plan for
anything and that affects
borrowing and that obviously that
affects lending
so at the same time now we're talking
about the
you know the you were talking about the
stigma of participating in
tarp among some small banks and people
because of
things like people are have been leary
to
participate in the public private
investment partnership and others
because they don't want to get close
to any sort of government control of
their business or
influence so i guess my main question is
how are you going to inject more
predictability
into the system you're talking about
this vague
notion of limiting tarp to 550 billion
dollars or so
and then focusing on small businesses
and um
and housing and um and and other
and i can't remember the last part
anyway but i'll leave that to you
how are you how exactly are you going to
um
put these uh funds to work what is the
general plan
well uh we there's a table attached to
my testimony that gives very detailed
estimates
on what we think a reasonable estimate
is a future program so it's very clear
and the programs have very clear
transparent conditions and one of the
things we did right from the beginning
was make sure we put
the specific terms of any contracts in
the public domain for everyone to see
so i think that uh we'll be very
effective and very clear
in making sure what the limits are going
to be in these programs what this
precise terms are going to be
now you're right that business across
america
still face a lot of uncertainty they
face a lot of uncertainty still about
how strong the recovery is going to be
and they face some uncertainty about
what the rules of the game are going to
be going forward and i think that that's
one good reason why
we hope the congress is going to bring
can bring to closure
the health care reform is moving for the
system and the broader changes ahead on
energy policy things like that i think
that will help reduce
uncertainty help improve confidence the
confidence businesses want to know what
the rules of the game are
and so i think i agree with you on that
you want to bring clarity
as quickly as quickly as we can well i
guess
again going back to the resolution
authority that you're asking for i think
that will just perpetuate
the lack of clarity relative to what let
me again let's just
think about the choice ahead do you want
to go back to a situation in which
the united states of america comes into
the worst crisis in generations
with no authority no ammunition no
ability contain the damage
it cannot be good for us to court that
disaster again
but it can't describe to ascribe these
particular
un uh undefined powers
they're very they're very well defined
and they're carefully limited
they're more limited in some ways that
those exist today and the ones that
we're creating that are new
are modeled on a resolution regime
established and tested for banks over
the decades well i agree with the
chairwoman that uh bankruptcy
is probably the best bankruptcy itself
for a quasi bankruptcy for banks
uh well a bankruptcy well i'm talking
about even beyond
the banking system um of uh of
firms that are not necessarily banks but
um you know are deemed to be
for some reason too big to fail or or of
a systemic risk and i think that's the
thing that we're concerned about
well again you know these are all about
choices
uh because i think many of us would
share the basic objectives
it was not good for the country to allow
very large
very risky complex institutions to
operate and effectively as banks
outside all the protections we put in
place for banks
in the wake of the great depression and
the crisis that preceded it that was a
terrible mistake
so institutions that effectively are
banks take
risk could imperil the system need to
have constraints on their opportunities
and that way we'll get another round
okay okay uh mr silvers
she's okay why don't you why don't you
finish that sentence maybe maybe you've
lost it maybe you've
lost it in the interim but um well i i
it's one of the hardest problems to
solve again
people don't know what the boundaries
are what the scope of this is
but again what caused this crisis what
made it so severe was
we allowed a entire separate system of
effectively banks
operating not just without constraints
on risk-taking that were adequate
you know this is investment banks aig
monolith insurance companies
you could say fannie and freddie too
and without the protections we put in
place to mitigate runs and panics
no that was the classic mistake of the
government
that's something we have to fix as part
of that need to be better tools to
manage failure with quasi banks
type regimes for those type of
institutions and mr secretary is it your
view that the bill currently
in the house which i understand the
administration supports
that that bill provides this fdic model
quasi bankruptcy process with no
provision for tarp-like equity infusions
other than to transition a failed firm
into an fdic-like resolution process is
that that's correct is that a fair
statement that's a fair statement
i mean let me just say that this issue
that has just been gone through is great
concern to me
i've looked closely at that bill i
thought earlier drafts were inadequate
in respect to this and
did did run the risk of another tarp i
think the bill that's in front of
congress today is the
is the right one and i think that your
leadership on this has been very helpful
the uh the uh
let me uh let me return to the broader
discussion about
panics and runs and so forth in the
context of aig i want to understand
better you the argument that you're
making
are you saying that the reason why
the credit that the counterparties to
aig had to be made whole
was not because of the threat that were
they not made whole they would fail
but because of the threat that if
anybody was not made whole
in a credit derivative transaction that
there would be a broader sort of
disintermediation of derivatives markets
is that is that your was that your
concern uh
i think you most were right but let me
say it slightly differently okay
if any if aig had defaulted on any
single counterparty
derivatives or any other contractual
obligation that would have forced a
generalized default
all right downgrade the system would
collapse was that that collapse would
have been
cataclysmic for the system as a whole
well default
is an interesting term here
a default is a it's a formal legal term
it's where the it's where the person who
has the obligation asserts that the
party hasn't paid and in that
circumstance the
the uh in that circumstance uh
uh perhaps can try to insist on payment
and
enforce a bankruptcy is it your view
that a negotiated haircut would have had
the same impact
because that would not be been a default
people negotiate haircuts all the time
between commercial parties
they do but let's just but that's your
but that's the point uh remember
this is not like there were three people
that had the total exposure of
counterparties and doritos to aig
there were tens and tens of
counterparties
on the drive side maybe hundreds there
were thousands of other counterparties
at stake in this context
no one would have been willing to
individually volunteer
a concession that stuff without it being
extended to
all other counterparties in similar
positions
it's a simple thing it's like flipping a
switch either
the firm is able to pay and avoid
default
or it courts default and downgrading
collapse no
is your view that and it's your view
that sig tarp is wrong
that there was an they appear to be
quite con this
uh sig tarp mr borowski and his staff
seem quite convinced
uh that there was an opportunity to
negotiate not a default
uh but a concession on the part of the
major parties and the chairman
in the real world the real world does
not work this way you don't you can't
run a strategy
on the hope that people will be nice and
decide they're going to voluntarily give
up
a set of contractual obligations and if
they're unwilling to do it
then your only choice is that you not
pay
and take control so your your concern
was that was the
default was the default of aig not a
broader run in the derivatives market
is that right or but was it both i think
part of
just think about what happened after
lehman it's the simplest way to think
about it
so what happened to lehman lehman failed
lee min defaulted
but then you're saying that the issue
was the default of aig
not a run on the i want to understand
whether you believe that
that derivatives markets in a crisis are
markets that have where everyone has to
get 100 cents on the dollar
all the time in a financial panic
in a generalized financial run
if you see cascading defaults like this
on any type of contractual financial
contract
that will accelerate not mitigate the
panic
again nothing would have been better if
there was a solution in place in this
case where you could have negotiated a
set of outcomes that left the taxpayer
with less exposure
to losses that has no realistic prospect
of success
in a financial panic of this magnitude
resolution authority would make some of
the choices a little bit easier
but there are no good choices in a in a
panic like that
i would just conclude that if
derivatives are those are if if
if derivatives are the kind of
instrument that have the kind of
importance in our
markets in which 100 cents on the dollar
is necessary in a crisis then we need to
regulate them as such
and we have proposed sweeping changes to
how
derivatives are treated and regulated in
our markets and partly because of that
risk
all right thank you superintendent
neiman i'd like to weigh in on the aig
issue for
one reason to to to just to confirm that
there is not necessarily a consensus
on this viewpoint on the panel but also
more importantly to delve into it
a bit deeper and also to encourage
everyone
uh to read that sig tarp report not
because of necessarily
the lessons learned but because it does
outline
the sequencing of events that led up to
and
uh describe that transaction my reading
of of that report
says that once the government decided
that
aig was too big to fail that was they
had no longer had leverage
over negotiating any of those haircuts
that is a very different situation than
was faced with the municipal issuers
of uh months earlier uh
i think it also indicated very clearly
uh
that uh of violating the the issues
around violating
uh the contractual obligations once the
government decided to
to uh to to uh to uh to prevent a
uh a default also treating u.s
counterparties differently than the
foreign counterparties would have raised
significant issues
utilizing the supervisory powers of the
federal reserve
uh to use that leverage to force
negotiation i think would also
have raised significant concerns and
lastly the issue that you raised of
of decreasing the uh of downgrades the
impact that would have
on the american taxpayer and the global
system so i
you know i would encourage uh everybody
to read that report
because of the descriptions and details
which to my knowledge were not
uh clearly outlined up to the issues
that report
but take disagreement with the lessons
learned and in my opinion the lessons
learned is that we did not have the
right tools for a resolution
of an institution of that nature and
that's why it is so critical
of that we have a a a resolution
authority to deal with systemically
institutions
uh well said and i think you said all
right i mean i think it's important to
recognize that it is a good thing for
our country
and this is going to happen for years to
come people are going to pour over
every decision we made they're going to
look very carefully at all those
judgments
it's of course hard to judge for the
benefit of hindsight what would have
been possible
uh and a lot of it's going to be hard
for anyone to appreciate who did not
live through
minute by minute what was happening in
that acute
series of financial panics with not good
choices for us
our job was to make a set of choices
among
unpalatable deeply offensive basic
choices
and do what was best we thought for the
country at that stage
but i respect the the efforts of people
to come back and look over this again
a lot will happen in the future we're
going to cooperate with it because the
american people deserve to try to
understand that
but again understand that no one really
can appreciate
the range of choices that are really
available at that time
and that's one reason why we have to
work so hard to make sure we have better
choices in the future resolution
authority allow these firms to fail
without the taxpayers being exposed to
the risk of loss
and that we do constraints on risk in
the future that can help mitigate the
moral hazard risk we see
you know before moving on to another
subject i'd like to use my remaining
time can you give us an update
uh on aig particularly what we're
reading in the press
about issues of risk of losing
individuals uh resulting from uh
from compensation uh uh directives of
from the uh from the uh well uh
there is there is uh risk of that as as
you expect and you would
um and you've seen i would say in
general
uh the management of new newborn new
management institution
are working very hard and effectively
to strengthen the underlying insurance
businesses therefore improving the
prospect of the taxpayer being repaid
and bringing down the risk in the
financial products division
that took the institution the edge's
collapse the risk and that is to come
down very very dramatically
overall scale of exposures and
derivatives are about half their peak
level
uh but that's the basic strategy is it
something that we should be concerned
about at this time
uh the impact to the american taxpayer
if
if if there is a a loss of
critical employees absolutely i mean we
need people who are
uh capable of running these businesses
the tax interest of the taxpayer and
making sure we maximize return on those
actions we took require there be capable
people running these firms running these
businesses
thank you thank you thank you mr
treasury our time grows short so we'll
enter the lightning round here
and try to get in at least one more
question i know you need somewhere else
at 12. uh we understand you're here with
us until 12.
so we will we will make so just until
like five minutes before 12
because i need to be at my next thing at
12 00. i thought we're gonna end at 11
45.
oh i think i was told we were ending at
12 that we had you for two hours
um so let me do ask that you'll have me
again i believe
but that's three months off um as uh
as the banks we're talking about how to
wind down tarps so here's my question
we've talked about the fact that the
guarantees for the money markets expired
on september 18th that's one of the
winding downs of tarp
but we jumped in we the federal
government we the treasury department
jumped in
when the money markets were about to
break the buck
now the money markets don't have any
official guarantees they don't pay
anything for any guarantees
but most of the market believes that if
the money market started to break the
buck again
there would be substantial government
assistance
you describe the banks as leaving tarp
they are stronger sure they're stronger
they've paid back their debts they have
no restrictions under tarp
but they also bask in the glow of
implicit guarantees after all we've held
up a big sign
that says those folks are worth saving
no matter what
so my question is how do we wind out
of implicit guarantees of the fact that
the market
sees and specifically assesses these
institutions
as stronger and capital as cheaper for
these institutions
for the specific reason that there is
this implicit government guarantee
i think the only way to do it is to put
in place financial reforms that achieve
two outcomes one is authority for the
government to constrain risk-taking more
broadly more effectively in the future
that is necessary it's not sufficient
and you need
quasi bankruptcy authority that allows
a credible risk that these firms can be
failed unwound
more safely i don't know a better way to
do it
i worry about the risk you laid out it's
inherent in any successful effort to put
out a financial fire
there is no way to put out financial
fire arrest a recession without taking
some risk you're going to
hurt future incentives in the way you're
described
the only solution to that is to change
the rules of the game
thank you mr secretary mr atkins thank
you very much
tonight can i just say briefly say you
said something very important in the
beginning
although you said in disagreement with
me but i want to underscore it okay all
right tarp
tarp was only one part
of what helped bring it back growth back
to the economy's stability back
tarp would not have been effective
without the guarantees put in place by
the fdic
without the broad measures of financial
market support by the fed and very
importantly without the recovery act
itself for things did not turn
things did not improve did not bottom
until you had that full arsenal of
policy responses deployed in parallel
it wouldn't have worked without tarp
tarp was necessary was not sufficient
and it was a part of that basic strategy
tarp can't claim the credit for all the
things that improved in this case
but it wouldn't have been possible
without it yeah well i you know the
recovery act is another whole issue and
i don't have time to go into that one so
i'll leave that
i do there are two things i wanted to
bring up one is
when you're discussing non-bank uh
non-banks non-banking firms whatever
before
i do have to note that many of them
fared a lot better than the huge banking
institutions that had
uh regulators and examiners living in
their
offices for example day after day for
example a lot of hedge funds and others
have a lot less
leverage two to one three to one than
the other sorts of um
i make that point a lot myself and i
grew that just my point out that was in
part because
we were actually quite effective in
making sure the institutions that
provide them leverage
that give them financing were much more
constrained than they were in 98 for
example
right but i agree with you so we'll have
to pick that one up i just want to
say that transparency i do believe is
the answer ultimately but
one other one last thing i did want to
point out with respect to the housing
issues we had a hearing um not too long
ago
with uh six folks and one of one of whom
brought up an issue
as to esa and the authority of treasury
to do some of the
programs that you're doing hamp and harp
because the statute talks about
how treasury will acquire assets meaning
you know loans or the underlying
mortgages or the securitized assets
and some of your programs are not geared
towards that
and so i wanted to legal opinion on that
i would so
i'm happy to homework for that happy to
provide thank you very much
thank you and mr silvers is going to
take the last question
i think in recognition of your time
considerations and uh
with us this morning mr silvers
um are you at all i've i've looked at
the composition of the revenue it's hard
to look at the competition the profits
of the four largest banks
over the last six quarters and it
appears that there's a trend
toward uh uh interest
income from loans uh declining slowly
uh and income from securities trust
revenue
again revenue from securities trading
increasing are you at all concerned
about
this about this essentially the quality
of earnings
within the four largest banks uh i'm not
at this stage i think actually they're
getting better not worse
uh i think the most important thing to
point out is that
what's happened to earnings across the
financial system is a direct function of
the fact that not just that the
government did extraordinary
things to save them from collapse but
that
the markets are now opening up firms are
able to raise capital again
and that healthy process of repair
companies able to go out and raise
equity raise debt again is a substantial
source of revenue that's what banks
exist to do
so i think it's largely a healthy thing
obviously we look at this very carefully
because what we don't want to do is
have a situation where the same type of
risks that brought the system to the
edge of the collapse
start to re-emerge again
thank you very much mr secretary i
want to say our characterization of the
past
may not always be in agreement but i
think we are very much in agreement
at least i hope we are that uh we cannot
go this way again there
there must never be a tarp 2.0 and this
is not over yet
you know we got work to do still to fix
what was broken not just put in place
reforms to prevent the crisis of the
future
thank you very much thank you this
hearing is adjourned the record will be
held
open for questions for the secretary